america's rear guard
army they wear no uniforms and their
ranks are
machinist welder riveter instead of
sergeant lieutenant and captain
but they are an army an army of 50
million americans doing the jobs that
must be done
to make america strong for victory their
health and strength
their ability to produce is the nation's
most vital resource
these people are america's industrial
army
our resources must be protected and here
protection starts
when the workers day starts it starts
with the milk we drink
most of our milk is pasteurized and then
bottled under conditions that protect
our health the water that flows into
most of our homes
comes from carefully guarded sources to
avoid pollution
and is kept at high standards of purity
the food we eat is inspected to protect
our health
sewage disposal in most of our cities is
scientific and
thorough to protect us against diseases
that are threat of
unsanitary conditions
and in hundreds of towns and cities new
homes have been built under government
sponsorship
homes that let in air and sunlight homes
that help
protect our health
these and many other precautions are
taken yet
when the working army of america goes to
the factories and shipyards and mines
a million men and women are missing
every day a million workers are off the
job because of sickness
it means that coal which is needed
remains in the earth
assembly lines are slowed down machines
untended it means 400 million days a
year
jumped in these millions of days lost
164 000 tanks could be built
a line of tanks that would present a
solid front over 200 miles long
the reasons for some of this loss can be
found in industry itself
there are the old reasons some jobs are
dangerous
some men are careless there are many old
industrial health problems not yet
solved and now there are new problems
new developments in industry new
machines and materials are creating
hazards
that further challenge safety control
and war production has brought the speed
and strain that spell
danger these are conditions that keep
tens of thousands of men off the job
every year
but the hazards must be controlled the
men must be kept
on the job so the question was asked how
can the wasted days be saved
this question was asked by some of the
men at the machine it was asked by
industry and it was asked by the united
states public health
service
in the research section of the public
health service scientists are searching
for the answer
they are searching for it in their
laboratories with experiment and study
with
equipment and men geared to do the job
they search for the understandings of
metal poisoning
for ways to fight dust hazards and
fatigue
they study the science of ventilation
and lighting
every problem of workers health is part
of their work
and the men who work here go to other
government agencies and to industry
and help them meet their industrial
health problems
here is the division of industrial
hygiene at work on a research project
a study of the hazards of changing
pressures
which affect tunnel workers and more
important to defense
aviators
in this pressure chamber the temperature
and pressure of different altitudes can
be reproduced
on solid ground the effects of flight on
the flyers body can be observed and
studied
there is danger to the aviator in the
swift and sudden high climb of the plane
and danger 2 in the hard driving power
dive
out of this laboratory study the
division hopes to take a weapon with
which to fight these dangers
the job of saving a day starts in the
laboratory
but it has to be finished in the plant
with the advice and assistance of the
public health service and state health
departments
many industries are doing their part of
the job with programs of their own
they are introducing pre-employment
examinations
which tell them if a man is physically
fit
for the job
and with a regular checkup they make
sure that the men who are
healthy stay healthy and those who need
treatment get it every one of these
precautions help
to save a day for the worker and his
family
for industry for the nation
and the well-run well-equipped
dispensaries of industry save many days
too
they keep a cut from becoming a
dangerous infection
and a minor eye injury from becoming
blindness
and equipment like the x-ray seen here
helps diagnose the broken
bone the lung infection and points the
way
to treatment
in studying the health needs of our
industrial army the public health
service works with other government
agencies for example
a call from the war department comes
through to dr townsend chief of the
division of industrial hygiene
asking that an investigation be made of
government-built and government-operated
arsenals
dr townsend and sanitary engineer
bloomfield
discuss the problem they decide to put a
field unit
on the job the decision made testing
apparatus is carefully checked
and then carefully loaded they take
instruments for measuring ventilation
instruments for determining dust
concentrations and for analyzing gases
and vapors it is not long from the time
the call comes to dr
townsend to the time the doctor and
engineer the field unit crew
live for the arsenal ready to start
their work
ready to track down the cause of a high
accident rate
or a strange skin rash or the feelings
of dizziness
that have suddenly attacked a group of
workers
the health forces of the nation unite
with the production forces
to protect the health of the workers to
save a day
wherever possible
and there are industrial hygiene units
which render similar services to
industry throughout the nation
units which are maintained by the state
health departments
in cooperation with the public health
service
the men of a unit search out hazards and
find
a way of removing them
dry drilling there is danger here
the engineer takes a sample of the dust
laden atmosphere to find out exactly
how great the danger is this
is a type of dust that leaves scars on
men's lungs
that may bring on tuberculosis that
sometimes
takes men's lives then back in a hotel
room only a few miles from the mine
the engineers set up their equipment and
make their tests
these tests will determine the number of
dust particles
their size and their nature on the basis
of this information
the extent of the hazard is measured and
the proper controls
recommended
after controls recommended by the health
department have been introduced
a stream of water keeps the dust down
keeps it out of the air out of the
worker's
lungs
bagging powdered mineral is another
industrial operation in which dust is
the danger
the engineer comes to the plant to check
and analyze the hazard and make
recommendations that will lead to its
removal
the operation is made safe by an exhaust
system which draws off the dust and
leaves the air
clear the engineer tests the exhaust
system to see if it draws strongly
enough
to take dust out of the room the powder
that seeps out of a bag
no longer fills the room like a cloud
but is sucked into the exhaust
but there are conditions that cause
illness that are harder to find and
harder to correct
and hereto the industrial hygiene units
do their work
they analyze gases chemicals and metals
investigate the causes of sickness among
workers
and the simpler things like recommending
goggles
and gloves and machine guards that too
is part of their job
state health departments and the public
health service are determined not to let
ill health become a bottleneck in this
crisis
to fight this danger they are expanding
their work in industrial hygiene
some state units are building trucks
that will make it possible
to take the laboratory and the clinic
right into the field
to the gates of the factory to the mouth
of the mine
in these trucks material can be tested
men
x-rayed and examined thoroughly whatever
the causes of ill health
all must fight to wipe them out federal
and state officials
industry and workers to industry the
public health service says
follow the recommendations of the
industrial hygiene division
of your state department of health to
the men on the job
find the safe way to do it and do it the
safe way
that is the way to save a day save a day
to keep them rolling
save a day to keep him flying
save a day that americans of tomorrow
may live in a land of peace
in a land where freedom reigns
you